It's the state of play, hip hip, hip, hooray, what a day!
It's the state of play at the end of May, hip, hip, hooray!
What else rhymes with play?
Oh, the state of play is finally today.
La la la.
Oh my God, it's June.
Oh, you're right.
State of play, we just passed May.
Hip hip hooray.
My sense of time is all messed up.
No, I wanted to go back to May so I have more time.
Pinkie me What does that mean Oily Oily Oily Kingdom Hearts
4 Please Square Enix Don't mind me I'm watching you while
wearing my Ace Combat robe Preparing for Sovereign Ritual
Could happen I mean they already announced something before
So good get more info Hip hooray, we're watching the state
of play.
They should hire, okay, do you guys wanna hear the music
that I was playing?
Wait, my music is much better.
They should hire me.
Instead, the music would sound like state of play.
I've run out of words.
Wait, hold on, words that rhyme with play.
You can tell I don't play Wordle.
Oh, it's the state of play.
Get ready, baby.
Get ready to pay.
It's the state of play.
We're here to stay.
Don't forget the survey.
It's the state of play.
It's also Rooks' birthday.
Rooks, happy birthday.
Hip, hip, hip, hip.
It's the same three notes over and over and over again.
Please, anything about control resonance.
I like when you guys tell me, when you guys come like, and
post stuff like, please this, please this.
And I'm like, I will tell them.
I am your direct line to, to, to, to Mr. PlayStation.
please please please let there be some info about kingdom
hearts okay i'll let them know now you are asking for it you
have no expectations you're just here to vibe i think what
people think that there's something about wolverine but
that's the only thing that i know mainly because it's like
what there's wolverine drinks or something or something
something still at work We'll have to watch the VOD.
Lance, good luck with the work.
Take it easy.
The rest of your day packing.
Thank you.
Yeah, today is just, I started a little early so we could
yep too.
But I, today I was packing and after this I'll be in
packing.
Hell, there is bubble wrap everywhere.
Everywhere.
Ah, you know it's a good state of...
Day when Minto doesn't let us PN.
Hip hop, all right.
Bloodborne 2 for real this time.
It'll happen.
If it doesn't, I'll suck on my big toe.
Do you have a bingo card?
I don't.
I don't know what to put.
Please release the Mim Fetum DLC for Delta.
It'll, it's any day now, any day now.
Anything spiral?
Actually, I want, I want AstroBot 2.
I want anything AstroBot.
That's my big goal.
AstroBot More.
That's what it can be called.
Sony.
Are you listening?
Wait.
Is Spyro owned by Microsoft?
I have no idea.
Wow, the colors.
The shapes.
Hey, Aminto.
I'm that bravely default cosplayer that talked about old men
and fandom.
Hey, you mentioned wanting to check out my love discerns
cover off hands.
Oh, it's on my this account.
Thank you.
Thank you, Super Tengu.
I copy, I save your username.
I'll look it up later.
Thank you.
Could I please get a happy birthday since you didn't see?
and i didn't see it no i'm so sorry happy birthday what the
heck i'm the worst i'm so sorry happy birthday happy
birthday sony announces combat by life will be yours we
already know eight is happening it got announced at least
yeah i would love to hear something about final fantasy 7
remake
Sorry, my music.
We're just in silence.
What else?
Announce it again!
Stranger than Heaven trailer.
More armored core.
Do you like Metroidvania's?
I can't say that I've played a ton of them, but the ones
that I have played...
I do.
No release date.
Patience.
What if it's like next week?
That'd be crazy.
That would be crazy.
I don't know.
There was a leaker and they said Sonic was getting a new
model.
Now no one believes them.
How?
I don't ever look at the leaks.
these kinds of things so how often are they accurate like
how often do do people like because it's it's kind of like
you know you can tweet anything you can kind of spitball
anything and maybe you'll get lucky but not that often never
not at all not very not often it's a coin toss it seems like
so such a silly side gig to be like, yeah, I am, I'm the
fake leaker.
Cozy, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I hope you have a cozy time.
Last of us remastered.
Especially if you're always wrong.
They were, but apparently Sony was really hyping this one,
so I'm, I'm excited for this and I'm excited for Summer
Games Fest, to be honest.
I don't know.
It's just kind of fun to get excited about these things.
I know so many people are like, the game I wanted wasn't
announced.
So I'm sad, but I just like, I don't know.
I get, I am, I think it's infectious that like, they're
excited and then I get excited.
I'm like, Oh!
Oh!
It's just kind of fun.
I don't know.
I love coping, inject opium into my face.
Yeah!
Not item, no item name.
Not item name.
Thank you so much for that.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Resumous.
Welcome back for 11 months.
Thank you so much.
there's been a lot of persona leaks lately people are
claiming that are accurate not sure of it myself but i sure
would be crazy to do it well i guess it's been a minute
since the last persona right actually but we had that like
other atlas game that came out met met a more more my more
Uh...
Morphi- Metaphor.
Metaphor!
It's been 10 years since the last new game.
Wait, it's been 10 years since 5?
Are you kidding me right now?
Koval, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Minto, have you ever been to an E3 or watched the live
streams?
I've never been to an E3 or watched the live streams.
been i've watched the live streams uh or watched some of it
yeah ultimate stooges welcome to membership thank you time
splitters four
p5 is a ps3 game
holy moly jaren thank you so much for the bow thank you
Congrats for Burn On.
Everyone did a great job.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thanks for 25 months as well.
I like your funny words, magic mode.
Holy cow.
I didn't even think about that.
But also, 10 years ago, and it's a PS3?
Not the PS4?
So strange.
Wait, that's so strange to think about.
Even... Wait, what?
Huh?
That makes no sense to me.
The PS3 was just that much of a powerhouse.
Honestly, like, one of the best consoles, says Mir.
Are you hoping for any announcements?
I mentioned AstroBot.
make news you know what i will even i'll throw i'll you know
what square enix you need to show up we need more kingdom
hearts news for real and ace combat eight of course ace
combat eight of course um honestly i just like to see new
ips and things it's kind of fun i don't
Um, I feel like we're doing such crazy good things with
horror in movies lately.
I would love a great horror game.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Half-Life 3.
It will happen today.
You have my promise.
My...
I've talked to Gabe.
Gabin.
I talked to that guy and he said don't tell anyone I'm gonna
whisper it down here
Half-Life 3 I said hey I'm not good at VR could you please
Could you please not have Could you please have Half-Life 3
come out So it's not just a VR VR Whoa, less than four
minutes!
If Gavin can count to three, maybe I'll play three.
Konami should just announce 10 Metal Gears.
I feel like we probably won't get anything Metal Gear today
because they did the Master Collection Volume 2 last time.
Need to see a Wolverine Collector's Edition, said.
What even is the Wolverine thing that people, isn't it?
Like they said it's a Like a drink or something at the
venue?
Have you heard the Ace Combat 8 theme that was released two
weeks ago?
I haven't yet!
Oh my gosh.
Have you seen Obsession yet, Minto?
No!
And I want to.
Oh my gosh, I want to go actually to the movie theater and
see it.
But I'm scared.
I have to go with somebody.
And I have nobody to go with.
Minto Gear Solid 2, Sons of Liberty remake.
Honestly, I didn't think...
As much as I enjoy Delta, a remake of any of the games I
don't feel like is really necessary.
I think it would be fun to get a remake of Metal Gear 1 and
2,
but...
You volunteer?
Okay.
Let's go to the movie theaters.
What if we all just get into a Discord call and talk the
entire time?
I will stream the movie.
I'll stream the movie, and everybody can be in a Discord
call, and we can just...
I hope they bring back the infamous games.
Oh, infamous, yeah.
Hi, Wi-Fi, hi, booze.
Hi, Dasko!
I hope you're getting rest after Dokomi.
Sign me up for this.
Sounds fine, actually.
I've thought about it, like, maybe in the Densetsu Discord
doing, like, a movie night, something, something.
I think it'd be kind of fun.
You got sick!
No!
Two minutes!
Curse of Khan.
Not even...
Not even the international cons are safe from Khan crud.
I
would love a Denchi movie night.
Yeah?
I can talk to Steiner about it.
See if I can do it.
Feels like it would be different than like a...
Than like just to watch along in members or something.
So...
Oh, will there be audio?
Yeah, I'll have audio, don't you worry.
I love being indie.
I love being indie!
I can play the video!
I usually get...
Not strike, but I get like a...
Oh, now this can't be played in all countries.
or something but one minute we got nothing ending credits
hope the announcement phantom 2 electric boogaloo boogaloo
german concrete build different no get drink lots of uh
electrolytes 30 sec here i'll i'll turn off my music we can
listen to the stinky playstation music for the 30 seconds 20
Six, five, four.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Let me know how the audio is, by the way, too.
Oh my gosh, PlayStation!
Oh,
he, wow, he, but that was so fast.
Wait, did you guys expect Wolverine?
Surprise, surprise.
Hi, I'm Marcus Smith, creative director for Marvel's
Wolverine.
Wow.
Today, we're excited to debut a new look at the game.
To set the stage, Wolverine is in a race against time to
rescue a group of kidnapped mutants before they're shipped
off to parts unknown by cybernetically enhanced mercenaries
known as the Reavers.
However, Logan quickly discovers he isn't the only mutant
attempting to save them.
Let's take a look.
Perfect timing.
Thank you for being first.
Step Wolverine.
Let's see if we can find the one that got away.
Is he gonna sniff it?
might be a ringlead he did he really did he's so hairy took
off into the industrial park I love this camo nobody can see
his bright yellow suit
bleb bleb Oh!
God!
I would be...
I would be terrified.
I would...
Oh.
It came off.
How to do that?
Logan don't play.
I didn't know his game.
Also, he's got a nice little booty going on.
Oh my god!
It's overkill!
Holy cow!
Oh my...
It's slide!
Blood resistance suit and skin, yeah.
Sorry, I didn't expect the green kid!
Leeds?
Is that his name?
I don't know anything about Marvel, sorry.
I'm sure that tomato juice will wash out, right?
Yeah!
Someone get Glorped out of the trailer.
Yeah, you need backup.
He does not come to play.
You cannot have Stormtrooper aim with this guy.
Oh my God.
Oh, is that?
Oh, brouche.
I don't know.
Gene.
Gene Gray.
Red!
I was close.
I was so close.
Rouge the bat.
She's flying.
And purple.
Oh, gameplay.
Slice and...
The slicing and dicing actually look so fun.
Oh my god.
This is so violent.
He's dead!
Oh, maybe he's not.
I heard him.
I thought their uniform said trash on them.
I think they say trash.
Zandats!
Exactly!
I was thinking of Revengeance 2!
Hey, you're taking damage, man.
You're no damage runners.
Oh, oh, he's gone psycho.
He's gone feral.
Oh my god, he's in psycho mood.
Oh my god.
I would also play dead.
I would just be like...
Throw me out of the truck.
Don't just don't.
Don't pulverize me.
Um, Ghost Rider.
Update from the Sony Live chat.
Oh, thank you.
They're saying the graphics are PS3 quality and spamming
about winning Destiny 3.
The live chats in these are always so funny.
He's a wild animal.
Yeah.
Um, the blood is too goopy.
Yeah, I have.
What would make it better graphics?
Is my question.
Like, what would you want?
Ulri made sure to wear his yellow outfit so he could have a
full ketchup and mustard look.
Loki hoping for PSP 2?
Wait!
You're cooking with that?
Sundowner, is that you?
For real.
Release the logs.
Oh my god!
I don't think you thought...
I didn't really think this went through.
Final destination.
This is exhausting me.
I need a break.
Wait, was that guy naked?
I looked away for two seconds.
I'm Glor!
Knock it.
I'm Wolverine.
The suit.
Oh, Deadpool!
Some folks can't wait to die.
That was Aquaman, right?
We hope you enjoyed that new look at Marvel's Wolverine.
Wow!
This is a single-player action-adventure game featuring a
focused, story-driven experience will send Logan on a
perilous journey across the globe where more than innocent
mutant lives are at stake Harley Quinn in this game mutants
live in hiding fearful of those who would hunt them down
while most of the world doesn't even know they shut up green
kid you'll encounter iconic Marvel characters like Jean Gray
mystique mystique I don't even see her oh my god we also
showed It's fast, fluid, and visceral in the way that only
Logan can deliver.
I like how it's like mutants are in hiding.
What is she supposed to do?
She's blue.
And we cannot wait for you to get your hands on it when it
launches September 15th, 2026.
We're also happy to announce that you can pre-order your
copy today at the end of the show in select markets.
Oh, that's right.
She shapeshifts.
I forgot.
On behalf of everyone at Insomniac Games, thank you.
You're welcome.
See you next time.
Coming to PS5.
Bud.
Hello and welcome to State of Play.
I wanted to start by thanking Marcus and the whole team at
Insomniac for that extended look at Marble's Wolverine.
That was wild and bloody.
It made me thirsty.
Everyone was so juicy.
And third-party studios from around the globe.
Let's get right to it with the latest from our friends at
Ark's.
system works x dev oh it's this one yeah yeah yeah oh so
much superhero
anime to face the supreme master of the pugilistic art the
duke of get your dukes up miss what
did she just say what i think she said than any word and the
greatest action is to fight you have to feel it so many
you've defeated whole world oh dr. doom let me show you why
you should leave thank you're a genius doom your works are
mere trinkets I'm gonna get your duke sucked dr. duke you
made promises doom and those promises magneto like the Big
guy just walking around in the background.
What is he doing?
He has no idea.
I will be the one to lead the way.
Ugh!
Queen Goblin!
You look a little angry, buggy.
You're still holding the ground.
Oh, the stages look awesome.
Time to stop laughing, Gobby.
Gobby.
Gob- Ow!
Wait!
What if he says Goblin these?
Oh gosh, wait, I hope so.
Goblin Ds!
Oh my god.
Don't be greedy.
Knights of Doom.
Everything is happening so fast.
I can't take in anything because it's all...
It feels like the Densetsu music video.
I'm like trying to see if with any details.
How?
That was so fast.
Oh no.
I see much from my perch atop the tree of tranquility.
Oh my god, little lizard!
There are some outcomes that are uncertain even to me.
Oh, he's so...
No, Rayman!
No, Stinking Way.
I love this chat so much.
Everyone is willing to give games a chance instead of
putting them down because they want big name games.
Yeah, we're pretty chill here.
We're just here to have fun.
Cute.
Reminds me of that octopus that like...
Octopus stealth game.
Konami is a good question.
Minto DMCA.
It's time to mind me.
My mark.
It's four against one!
You don't stand a chance!
Maybe he stands a little bit of a chance.
Clobox to the rescue!
Oh no.
Ooh, spooky.
Somehow Palpatine returned.
I wasn't too far off, was I?
Is he gonna do a...
He is right behind me, isn't he, Joke as well?
It's four against one, you don't stand a chance.
Erm, maybe you stand a chance.
October 1st!
Lots of coming in the September-October, right?
Dave the Diver!
I love this game!
Dave the Diver, too?
Expansed?
We've...
We've gone...
Prequel?
Oh my god!
We get to be Bancho!
Oh!
Right!
Do we still get the fish?
Big question.
She's so cool.
Hiroshai.
Oh no, it's a cooking game.
And a fly swatting game.
A cracking game?
Dishwashing game.
Fishing!
Oh, Bancho the chef!
Old lady game?
Captured on PS5 Pro.
Cat girl.
Oh,
these are like crazy yokai.
It's Fortnite?
Dang it.
You are a yokai hunter!
Why?
Hunt the unseen.
Tango is so cool!
Whoa!
Where are the ghosts at?
Paranormal!
That's me!
Oh
Three-player co-op Oh, you really aren't alone Huh
Yo-Kai Hunters run dead since I was thinking that too!
Oh, pretty late.
It's astronaut!
Astrobot!
These designs are... Wow!
They're so fun!
I'm pretty.
Hi everyone!
It's a good day.
I'm Shinra Nakamura Ikumi Did you miss me?
I miss you!
I'm so cute!
Look at me!
Today I'm going to show you guys the action game, KEMRI.
This is KEMRI City.
This world and that world are all together.
Ikumi love!
Cool.
Foxy window.
That's cool.
to carry the animal.
And they will carry themselves.
And using the fear of the universe and power to carry a
power to use a cool apparel with a cool apparel and super
power to the more powerful powers of the world.
So there are three types of weapons.
One is a sword and a crown.
One is a hammer.
One is a bow hunter.
Next, sharma.
Sharma!
And as you know, there are multiple ways.
There are multiple.
So you fight yokai, but you make contracts to use their
powers?
I know three players, a game about yokai, an idol group with
three yokai members.
Shushu Shushu Shushu Shushu Shushu Shu Shu Shu Shu Shu Shu
Shu Shu Shu Shu Shu Shu Shu Shu Shou Mora Craft Captured on
PS5 Pro Then halfway across the continent Yo-Kai-mon if only
Yo-Kai watch was still relevant And so if we make a contract
with you, what kind of powers do you bring?
I won't let you.
My contract is too steep.
I'm having some candy that Vicky gave me.
When it comes to retrieval, your
money or making the world a better place.
This is a puzzle.
I love puzzles.
You don't strike me as someone who walks past a locked door
without wondering what's behind it.
She's so beautiful.
I can only trust you with this.
Dinosaur!
Miss Croft!
You're speaking my language.
My love language.
Oh, no!
Oh, yeah.
I gotta say, I captured your good side.
I love that we have Laura Croft, and we have Indiana Jones,
and they're both so sexy.
You're assuming I've got a bad side.
Ooh.
Ooh, tell him.
Oh, she's so hot.
Yeah!
Survivor outfit.
So, what was your favorite from today?
That's what it looks like in that new movie, the Alice.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I think my favorite is the Diplodocus.
No!
Papa!
I'm fine.
The baby.
Wait, that's trying to...
Oh, that's me!
I think we all know someone who's going to wishlist.
It's not a game reveal stream without Mickey popping a vocal
cord.
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
She hasn't been this excited since MGS Delta was announced.
I had no idea!
In this open world survival RPG, you can fully immerse
yourself in the world of Dune.
I didn't think that I would see him!
That's crazy!
Intrigue featuring many of the characters from the books and
movies.
Find the Fremen.
Wake the sea.
Oh, from the books is cool.
Alone or with friends, you will explore...
Wait, uh, uh, uh, uh, Dune has a Timothy Shalomey.
Is he in the cave?
Keep it up, we love to see it.
Sorry.
You'll discover new technologies, craft gadgets and
weaponry, and build a base of operations that will grow and
expand as you progress towards power and fortune.
I hope not.
Pursue the path of the Bene Gesserit, Swordmaster, Trooper,
or Mentech, and master anything from mind control to brutal
hand-to-hand combat.
You mean close quarters combat.
You can choose to play with your friends or alone.
So this means Hot Tomb Raider is like 2% the excitement of
our boy kids.
It's just, it's just, you know, I don't get a lot of chances
to see him in games and stuff.
I didn't think I would see him today at all.
Dune Awakening arrives on PS5 on September 22nd.
And also dinosaur games are fun!
like the fan favorite PSD classic Dynasty Warriors 3 is
getting remastered for PS5 Muso Medjin Dynasty Warriors 3
complete edition remastered but um I feel like dinosaurs are
coming back into popularity established the foundation of
the series with Disney getting rid of dinosaur I just want
them to know that they made a huge mistake and I want to rub
it in their faces Timothy will be busy with the Knicks for a
while what's that joining the battle is Zawan the
protagonist from Dynasty Warriors Origins.
Yeah, Doki will be hyped.
Where's Awangyuanji?
I like her.
Dynasty Warriors 3, complete edition remastered, launches
later this year.
Immediately loses hearing, the window screen.
I'm so sorry!
From the award-winning studio behind the Ori series, comes a
bold new vision for action RPGs.
What is it?
No rest for the wicked is a kind of themed vengeance I
aspired to bring back the dinosaur hand puppets they need to
bring back dinosaur everything hand-painted world you can
explore alone or share with friends in your own persistent
realm a world that evolves even when you're offline oh the
highly anticipated full 1.0 release expands everything a
massive world 1.0 release everybody system and hundreds of
hours of content including end game all with full cross-play
and cross-save hundreds hundreds of hours of content this
October that sounds like a threat weeks of fun weeks of fun
let's check in with Capcom for an update on Onimusha way of
the sword doesn't matter a beast isn't far from anoni you
know you do well to follow his I thought you'd see the
appeal, Musashi.
I think it's great that games will give you your money's
worth in that kind of way.
But at the same time, who's got time for that?
Oh, these guys are icky.
I sense Gengma.
Prepare yourself.
No ordinary Gengma can move like that.
He said it was Capcom.
I doubt this area was designed to welcome visitors.
The castle's owner must be terribly cautious.
Some folks only buy a couple of here.
That's true.
And some people really like to sink their teeth into a game
for hundreds of hours.
You shame yourself, child.
If you live by the sword, fighting is everything.
So you've lost.
Will you swap the sword for a trowel?
Like hell I will.
No.
What then?
Are you going to start taking human souls?
A second sword.
If human souls are what it takes.
Masashi.
If that's the path here, I won't follow.
I've chosen to trust Masashi's judgment in all matters.
Why are they like British?
Give me every ounce.
They're following Xenoblade.
Dubbing.
In return.
Then get going.
Onimusha.
September.
Lots of stuff for September.
September and October so far.
Cute!
Dog!
We can't wait to get our hands on Onimusha Way of the Sword
this September.
But you won't have to wait long to try it yourself.
Here's one more update from the Onimusha team.
Oh, Demo?
Demo is here.
Tense sword played out.
She can predict the future.
I've already watched this direct.
Not direct state of play.
Zinovention?
Make sure?
Oh my gosh!
That thing's ugly.
Oh my gosh.
Take me out to dinner first.
So aggressive, we just met.
Do you think this is the new Silent Hill?
Oh, wait, I think it's the new one.
Oh my gosh.
The town.
Yeah, it is!
It's the new Silent Hill.
Hey, who's there?
Me.
I mean, don't...
Say that.
Oh, you have like a little radio.
Please say something.
hi where did you go Simon what doesn't feel right I
shouldn't
oh SH silent hill Zoe I'm sorry I Zoe What are you doing
here?
Ew.
Good plan.
Just a guy.
And he's naked?
Oh, even worse!
Oh, God.
They're like, how can we make these monsters scarier?
Remove their clothes.
Uh, what does that mean for...
If it's his inner manifestations?
I'm so sorry.
Fear the truth behind the static.
Oh, Townfall!
That's what it was.
Silent Hill Townfall.
He's an exhibitionist.
The target is the front gate of the capital of our homeland.
The Federation of Central Yuzha.
Ah!
It's here!
Back from our enemy!
him the one whose rear will have to cover the people left
behind back of the continent needs something to hold on to
some sort of symbol that inspires hope we will be in visual
range of the way it'll be soon
oh where are you going copter cover tasha rex
That's where the wings of Thieve comes in.
MF?
Mint Phantom?
D.D.
wants the legendary savior to get as much publicity as
possible.
More exposure?
The better.
Turn it up.
All aircraft pulled out.
Sorry, Rex.
You stay put, Joker.
Rex?
Above you, Christ, the wings of Thieve.
No harm will come to you.
reach the terminus fingers what the imposter sharing
information isn't always about telling people the truth
whoa we dangled the bait and wings took it we'll find out 22
would you please we've got a leak is it time to run ray hang
on ah another elevator i know Come on, Ray.
Let's go, Rex.
Wait, Ray or Rex?
Go take what's yours.
October!
Everything is in October in September!
Wims of Receive!
2026, 10-202.
Early Access will be 9-29.
In this video,
Happy birthday?
Right, actually!
Oh my gosh, it's the day after my birthday!
This is the day after my birthday!
Did you know there are three kind of aces?
Zero!
Oh!
This is Ace Combat 8, Wings of Sieve.
Downloaded one is a pre-order and package one is an
in-storey purchase Ace Combat 0, the Velcan War, Strange
Real!
Strange Real!
More to look at more More to the end of the game!
Prepar for takeoff!
What, what, what?
Yeah!
Ace Combat News!
Cars?
Hot Wheels?
New Forza?
Oh my god.
Happy early birthday MF Rex.
Someone's gonna be busy in the fall.
For real though!
Actually!
What?
The Delorean?
Huh?
I think we got it.
Yep, roll playback.
Stunt man.
Wait, that sounds kind of sick.
Wait, that seems pretty fun though.
Huh?
There's a wounded man.
Nasty injuries.
It's like a beast torn apart.
Oh, oh, middle gear.
Out here.
Are you drunk or something?
It's been nine years.
Still weak, so be careful.
Where are I?
What's going on?
Wait,
this is like spooky-ish though.
Oh, goodness gracious.
Oh, God, I'm glad it's not Metal Gear.
Oh, I'm really glad it's not Metal Gear.
What the heck?
What do you mean, save your ammo?
I'll...
Die, bastard.
And you're tough.
lively for someone who just came out of a coma don't tell me
it was a nine year ago someone played mgsb and was like what
if they had more zombies in it from the moon
but you must don't say house or the dead that'd be insane
okay my chances turns out i'm a lucky man are sickening
though this is crazy you'll find nothing there
but death it's like a house full of dead ishmael looking a
lot more chipper 27.
keep quiet in there
ew oh it is called you ew goodness gracious
all of these start with like a jump scare have you noticed
that eel something is coming I have to go it felt like an
earthquake but it was just a paper clip oh falling off a
desk oh the tiniest tremor before the main event just I know
what they put you through.
You never had a chance.
Control.
Ah!
Control Resonance.
Ah, ah, ah!
I sing stand right now, Dylan.
You're our only shot at survival.
Freaky.
Yeah, isn't there?
the same universe as alan wigg should i should i be closing
my eyes you're not even human oh my goodness swore for years
and forgot about me yeah the hiss it was a way out yes and
yes i do not listen Does it matter?
Wow.
September!
Everything is September!
In October!
What is happening?
Oh.
We're gonna have a lot of fun together.
Everybody's wallets though if everything is released at the
same time.
That's ridiculous.
Captured on PC.
I like
the colors.
Oh.
Wasn't this announced already this game?
For those without eyes to see.
Marathon.
Oh, it's released.
I don't pay attention.
Do FPS games ever?
It's full on out.
Oh, okay.
So, like, new update or something.
New season, maybe.
It's out already.
Your birthday month is going to be popped.
For real!
Free to play week.
Um.
Ew.
I'm seeing mixed feelings in the chat.
That's okay.
It's fine.
It's A.
New zone, new shell, new... Oh, don't expect me to read that
so fast.
Okay.
The dangerous and cutthroat world of Marathon expands today
with its second season, Nightfall.
And if you haven't checked out Marathon yet, Bungie
announced an open trial period for the launch of Season 2.
You'll also be able to pick up Marathon at a discount.
Now, let's take a look at what's coming soon to PlayStation
Plus.
Up first, a beloved fantasy world is finally coming to
PlayStation for the first time.
RuneScape Dragon Wilds is an open world survival game.
where you rise from survivor to dragon slayer runescape play
solo or with friends as you explore ashen ball a beautiful
dangerous new frontier in the runescape universe where power
is earned and every action deepens your master runescape
with magic at your command you hear that deadly terrain mass
forage in seconds uncover hidden paths and outmatch brutal
Master magic, melee, and ranged combat, and push deeper into
uncharted regions of Gilinor.
Build a home together, farm the land, and fish the waters.
Fish!
Make it yours.
Whoa!
RuneScape Dragon Wilds arrives day one on PlayStation Plus
later this year.
Oh, okay.
Wait, what does it...
Oh, oh, I'm...
Oh, okay.
The day it's released, the day one...
Classics catalog over the next few months.
Five hours of AFK mining.
In June, battle colorful enemies with musical instruments
and Guitar Room Man, one of the most stylish rhythm games
from the PS2 era.
Oh my god!
What?
Yo!
In July, SciOps, the Mindgate conspiracy joins the Classics
catalog.
This PS2 action adventure mixes running gun gameplay with
psychic powers.
Wow!
Wait, psyops!
And finally, Onimusha Dawn of Dreams, a Capcom classic from
2006 launches later this year in August.
Holy frame rate.
Dragon Wilds has too many pixels for me, sorry.
No, I agreed to be honest.
Wow.
Oh, PlayStation.
Akashima Island.
Haunted by dark stories.
Our goal.
I like haunting.
Kitaruma, my beloved.
This is dead true.
International.
Thanks.
Come on, let's get a photo together.
Is this like a like a super massive dark pictures game?
Rotated on that one.
Hey, forever, dude.
Who's the buff idiot?
If it's like until dawn.
Does no one know this guy?
Like the quarry.
Oh, you two haven't met yet, right?
Sebastian.
I'll be looking out for you.
Roland, whenever you're ready.
This facility has been shut down for days.
decades i'm investigating i'm tall until now oh if it is
it's so up my alley what they're literally rolling in the
flowers looks so oh no this might be exactly the trash that
i want to eat singer sounds like you what do you mean we
gotta go
Oh my god, everybody is...
Until I die.
We're gonna have to jump!
There's rocks down there!
Oh, push!
Wait, it's already good!
Oh my god!
Oh no.
You do what needs to be done.
Oh, I'm so excited.
What?
It's until dawn too!
It's actually until dawn!
I hope you enjoyed the first look at our brand new
installment of Until Dawn.
What a strange timeline we are in for Rootscape to be
showworthy in 2026.
Oh!
My god!
I'm obsessed.
I'm so excited.
I can't wait to play it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for feeding me.
I'm so excited.
one more game to show and it is something special this is a
brand new title debuting with more than 20 minutes of
uninterrupted game oh that's a long time wait it's a brand
new wait did you say it's a brand new what 20 minutes that's
a really long time
bird those
birds morning dove
they're not showing anything on purpose I feel like this is
a I feel like this is a title people know
God of War
you are free I guess so yeah oh my god oh my god Wait, what?
Wasn't there more?
What was the last God of War thing that was announced?
It was the last...
There was something.
Oh, it was the remake.
That's right.
Spreading her ashes to the sad...
Hole?
Mom of War.
war.
Oh!
Mom of peace?
It's like not quite a sequel, right?
It's like a branching of this main story.
Those are always kind of fun.
Yeah, spin-off.
Ew!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's Stupid.
Even better.
Yeah.
Okay.
Burned clothes.
The pyre.
It happened.
They're starting on the path.
It's just...
I didn't get to say goodbye.
Aw.
Well, guys, we got this for 20 minutes.
Marketable plush creature.
Yes, absolutely.
Yeah, I don't know where to go.
I need yellow paint.
That's promising.
Oh god!
Maybe we don't stand right next to the person that is dead
for whatever reason they could be.
Free sword?
Oh, dang.
Mom is cool.
Press R2 to activate your mom vision.
Okay, mom.
Mom of war.
I hope it's called that.
It would be so funny.
What do you have?
A knife!
Glowing gecko friend.
It's like a little fuzzy.
It's goofy looking.
You can see why Kratos married her?
Yeah.
Oh, look at his eyeball.
Oh.
Now, how about a way out?
I don't even know how to pronounce what you just sent,
Songo.
Thank you for the super chat, though.
Oh.
Good job, thing.
We could do that.
Or we could crawl.
Whichever.
Oh, Minecraft.
Oh, my God.
I still find my own way from here.
She got teleported.
Isekai to Minecraft.
Wait, this is Alex.
Oh my god, you guys.
This is probably the prequel to the Minecraft movie.
No, it can't be it.
It's not possible.
I cracked it.
I cracked the code.
My path isn't safe.
Oh,
it's stupid even better is what they say about me all my
life.
Boy, trickin' jocky.
You guys can spread my code and my theory around.
I allow you.
Mom of War.
Norse mythology does have a lot of mine and craft.
That's what I'm saying.
Spread my code.
Oh!
Punch him, punch him again!
Did she come from the Aegon Oslo?
The gateway is closed.
Whoa.
I like your gods.
I like your tongue.
Ratowskir from Norseman.
Steve is NTR.
I don't think they're together, right?
Why does this not look like Norse though?
This looks...
Like it...
Oh no!
Did they just throw him into the fire?
Yeah, it looks like...
Oh, God of War isn't only Norse.
Oh, is it?
Okay.
Yeah, it might be a different thing.
mythos that'd be cool oh god of war was originally greek oh
okay i don't know much about it at all yeah like he looks
like like east asian
mythology damn taste oh yeah oh yeah oh so cool Maybe a Jin?
Oh, maybe.
That'd be cool.
Them chompers.
She's in a very Chinese time of her life.
Or her afterlife, apparently.
She's just like me, for real, for real.
Oh, no.
They're gonna be all like, wait.
And she's like Egyptian.
They're gonna be all like PDA in front of her after she just
died in front of her husband.
I don't wanna watch.
Another mask.
This is important to you.
I wish she had more snakes.
I wonder.
Do you think this could set you free?
Honestly, I wish these trailers would do.
Would do subtitles too.
You touch me again, and I swear, I will kill you.
Would you like to see how hard it is to die here, godly?
I can show you.
Whoa.
Oh, dang.
You can't keep me here.
The gateway is closed.
There is no escape.
Resisting the truth.
Will only make this more pain.
No.
Let's see.
I will handle that problem.
Deal with our new pet.
Whoa!
Big kitty.
Like lizard kitty.
Actually, maybe made for me.
Lizard flying kitty.
Skinless cats.
Skinless cats?
What?
What do you mean, skinless?
Just be careful.
Oh.
Fresh air.
Oh, you're different.
You're a cube.
What?
It doesn't matter.
How do we get out of here?
Yeah.
We've tried.
There's no way out.
And you're a talking sword.
A talking sword and a talking cube.
And the ribbons, obviously.
And my name is Rude.
the cube is frank frank the cube i'm sorry being for real
right now okay maybe it really is a micro way out of course
i'm not here oh you have to be dead to come through the
gateway it's like you're holding something back this isn't
working That cat's not dead, is he?
Where are we anyway?
Afterlife of the gods?
I call it the everyone.
Why is the afterlife of the gods so stinky?
Hey, Frank the cube, would you?
Not your boss, Frank.
It is God, heck.
Yeah, it's just...
So we could get gods from every, like, culture.
That's fine.
explosion happen right could you do that again my magic it's
wrong here I feel wrong here you won out right I think we
all want that we definitely do fate you need to accept it
all of it you're dead how how do I accept that simple focus
you're here be here be yourself these all the greek gods are
here but what if i need to be somewhere else wait everyone
that like kratos fought and stuff
mom powers r2 to mom
so i don't i don't know if i'll ever play god war i don't
it's not that i just don't have quite of an interest in it
okay we'll take it so if anyone wants to spoil does she come
back in like or she dead dead in the series
she's dead dead she
has not come back in the other games got it Kratos.
Kratos.
Oh, she's the Lulu.
Thanks, Kratos.
For your help.
Oh, gosh.
Look, I just flew.
We're flying, for real.
Oh, Frank!
Really?
I think you should give her the sword.
How do I know I can trust her?
I'll give it back.
Does that not hurt him or...
Kratos dies the most out of, like, all the gods?
He's...
He's Goku?
Ew.
Whoa.
Give it a little bit of that mom touch.
even use the sword.
Oh, you separate their souls from their bodies?
Shira.
Not until I get you out of here.
Not until I get you out.
I don't need help.
Here we go.
Coming up behind.
Just open it.
Yeah, they're already dead so you can't like just, well I
guess you can kill their bodies but you have to be a little
extra about it.
Whoa!
Frank co-op?
I want to play as Frank?
You play as mom?
This fuels the higher playing theory about gods.
What's that?
I don't know anything.
I got a promise to keep.
Fine, but lady, that sword.
It's more than you think it is.
Wait, you saved that guy, but he doesn't even know who you
are?
Hmm.
I will kill you.
Don't make promises you can't keep got them.
That was cool.
Here comes Frank.
Coming from behind.
Oh, Frank dodged.
Good job.
Is that blood on him?
All right, Frank, going for the hit.
Oh.
Hey, focus.
You
don't know what you will.
Oh, nice one!
You're scared of this sword.
Why?
I fear nothing.
Oh my gosh, wait, what if it's been Frank Sinatra?
He really was a god.
Regrets?
I've had a few.
Frank is the new boy.
Kratos has a son and we get Frank.
This...
It has to be sexist somehow.
What's wrong with Frank?
No, I'm actually his biggest fan.
I think it's so funny.
Mint, I'll be Frank.
Turns into a cube.
God of lore?
Mom of lore.
Mom of war.
Levee!
That's my favorite singer!
Why?
Ew.
Silent heel.
Dinosaurs.
God of war, Frank.
Chad Frank vs.
Boy.
Oh my gosh, until Dawn 2.
I am so hyped.
I'm so hyped.
Wait, did they say when until...
I think until Dawn 2 was 2027, right?
Frank of War.
Mom of Frank.
Levy was Faye's actual name as a giant.
2027.
Frank really squared up to fight a god, no fear.
Ah!
Until Dawn, too.
Ace Combat, Ace!
Oh, that Kamuri game was pretty fun, too.
That was fun.
A very mint-coated state of play.
Thanks for the watchalong.
I can't believe it.
Honestly.
Can we watch Ace Combat again?
Doubt soon enough.
Would you please?
Green fight is the best of maneuver.
We've got a leak.
Is it time to run, Ray?
Hang on.
Joker 1.
Did you go Rex?
Let's go Rex.
Let's go Ray.
I'm having an identity crisis.
Rise above.
Wait, hold on.
Where was it?
After Tomb Raider.
What was this called again?
I don't know.
I have to... I didn't even...
I have to wishlist it.
I don't know if I can do this.
Oh my god!
They're so scary!
This is gonna be such a good horror game.
Ace Combat.
I'm gonna buy Ace Combat Day 1.
You should!
There's always a choice.
The Lost Wild.
now.
I will.
Thanks for asking.
Imagine just the time for my birthday!
Oh, sorry.
The trailer started playing.
Just wanted to say thank you for being my kami.
I was saying, we thought you were silly.
Dorky antics have always brought my day in hard times.
So here's another great, too.
Another great year.
Viking Lake!
Bye!
Okay, so my most anticipateds are coming out next year.
I'll wait.
Oh, holy.
Oh, my God.
He's in the picture!
He's on the Steam page!
True fear is primal, embarked on an evasion-based survival
horror experience against nature's ultimate hunters,
dinosaurs, explore overgrown research facilities nestled in
a lush wilderness, be resourceful as you evade, distract,
survive, and unravel the mystery at the heart of the island.
Oh!
I'm excited.
I'm so excited!
Ketzel, he's there, he's there, hold on.
Copy page URL, hold on.
Maybe I can show you guys.
Uh.
Wait.
Was this show?
Oh.
Look!
There's also a new...
dinosaur movie coming out it's like this the the what is it
like the the end of the street something something i don't
remember but it also seems to have an allosaurus in it which
is which is interesting we're we're getting away from
t-rexes it seems the pretzel
oh it looks so these guys are terrifying i'm scared i'm
scared and excited Oh, yeah, Ace Combat.
Wait, Silent Hill.
That was crazy.
Silent Hill into Ace Combat.
What is happening?
What is going on?
Oh, my gosh.
What the hell is that?
There's more of them.
I'm so sorry.
What is it?
Hold on.
I was trying to read what the sign said before.
Justice.
Just as something South Well.
Let the fairies, a crime on our community.
This town is bonkers probably.
This town is over, maybe.
Whatever heart this town had has stopped.
Oh my god.
We need the truth.
And then C-E-G?
C-E-G, yeah.
Hmm.
Interesting.
CED is a company, I guess?
They're protesting against it?
Hmm.
I'm so sorry.
Mito!
Hello!
Maybe we worked for that company, whatever it was.
Hmm.
The target is the front gate of the capital of our homeland.
The Federation of Central Yuzha.
from the sea and take the capital back from our enemy and
then also what the hell is we have this hello good night
Minto good night from the wind this this this where are you
going cop there that's where the wings of Thief comes in.
Railgun warship.
And F.
Nick Phantom.
And your name is Rex.
This game is made for me.
I say it now.
Felicity is possible.
Your exposure?
I see.
It looks so pretty too.
Seven was very pretty also.
This game looks very pretty too.
Above you, fight the wings of thieves.
Whoa!
Sheesh!
Sharing information isn't always about telling people the
truth.
And then also, we get a zero too?
Hold on, sorry, I'm skipping forward now.
Did they say it was...
It wasn't a remake, was it?
Or...
Early Access September 29th, okay.
It's still cool to have, be able to be able to get it again.
Still cool to have, be able to get it again.
pre-order bonus wait so if unless you pre-order the game you
can't didn't they do this before didn't they do this before
where if you pre-ordered the game or something you got what
was it not four five or something they did it with seven
yeah And then They're doing it again
They did it for 5 on the PS4 Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
So, hopefully it gets another release later They did that
for Ace Combat 7 If you bought the PS4 version You got a
remaster 5 Yeah Oh, and if you bought the Xbox version You
got 6 Oh, gotcha, gotcha I'm excited though to play Zero So
Yippee Yeah!
Yippee!
Bonus for the digital version and the early purchase bonus
for the physical version.
well thank you guys for joining me for um state of play
today i'm so hyped state of play hip hip all right tribe
princess thank you yeah it was so fun it was so fun very
hyped yiffie that was so fun yeah i hope you guys had fun
too i have to keep going i have to keep packing
unfortunately so i got a skedaddle but um yeah thank you
guys thank you thank you and get high get high for september
get high for october get high for 2027 until dawn 2 i must
keep streaming until dawn 2 i that gear that is uh what's
the word um job security for me Please stream guitar, oh
man, and you'll have my soul.
I want to, I want to.
I never got to play it, but I just know about it.
You sang pre-order bonus out of the blue scared me.
Sorry pre-order bonus, but thank you so much for the 25
months.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yippee!
Eh.
Thanks for watching with me.
Thank you!
Otavito everybody!
Thank you so much!
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time.
Showing and I will haunt you later!
Haunt you later!
Actually.
I'm always haunted.
What's it y'all?